até mesmo os produtos de limpeza que
utilizamos em nossa casa podem afetar a
nossa saúde pesquisas recentes da
Universidade de Harvard apontam que o
uso constante de alvejantes e
desinfetantes Pode sim aumentar o risco
de desenvolvimento de doença pulmonar
grave a chamada DPOC uma siga que
significa doença pulmonar obstrutiva
crônica e sabe o que é mais assustador
usar esses produtos apenas uma vez por
semana pode elevar em até 32% a chance
de você desenvolver essa doença pulmonar
ao ao longo dos anos que existem algumas
diretrizes de cuidados ao usar esses
produtos Como utilizar a quantidade
adequada sempre usar máscaras e luvas
Principalmente quando manuseamos
produtos fortes como a água sanitária na
hora da Faxina lembre-se a quantidade
recomendada no rótulo é a chave mais
produto não significa necessariamente
mais limpeza e abra as janelas Mantenha
o ambiente arejado e se você costuma
usar esses produtos potentes em casa
sabe que existem opções mais naturais
igualmente eficazes que podemos utilizar